this is code dive and our next speaker
is alexi pilkevich now alexey is a
student
at rotsuav university of science and
technology and works at nokia
as python developer for test automation
he loves sports and psychology and
stand-up comedy
and if triggered he can go on about
prog metal bands on n and he can talk
about it
until your head explodes so
his talk is called async oh wait alexi
so
some prog metal references are fine but
explosions well
maybe not today other than that off you
go
i always wished i could drink coffee
like that from the comfort of my own
home
on other cold dives now
today we are going to talk about essence
io
and i am going to
present how i would like
to have i think i thought to me
when i was first starting out so if you
are
already an experienced programmer
and experienced with a cinque ho this
might be a little bit
boring for you but you still might find
something interesting
um in the way i give my own spin to the
basics of async io if you are a beginner
it should give you a solid foundation
so let's get started
there comes a time when you
want to do a bunch of stuff at the same
time
and when such need arises
you remember that oh there's
uh this framework in python i heard
about it's called snko
so you go to the internet and you copy
the first
hello world example
[Applause]
it goes something like this
[Applause]
you write a normal function with a
little bit of weird syntax
and then you run it
also in a bit of a weird
way
and that works it prints hello sleeps
for one second
and prince goodbye but you might notice
it's not happening at the same time
so if you're like me you think aha
i need to have two of those
so you make another function
and you decide
to call the first one twice from it
so far so good
let's run it
turns out it's still happening
sequentially
so why why is that because
intuitively when you look at this await
it kind of tells pyson okay at this
point
you are free to do whatever you want to
do and you can then come back to finish
it later right
well turns out no because
it's not happening at the same time so
then you go to the docs
and you find out that what you have to
do
is you have to use some kind of
snko function to
wrap those two coroutines in
into one avoidable object
and once you do that using asynchro
gather
you can notice finally that it's
happening at the same time
now honestly the first time i did
something like this
i thought okay this works nicely
uh the only problem i have is that i'm
using some weird functions here
so why don't i just go ahead
and do the sleep
the way sleeps in python are done
and when you run it you may notice
it's happening sequentially again so why
is that
you're using this gather function to
wrap those two quartens
the score routine has a sync keyword
here
oh maybe you can await
ouch turns out you can't
so this is when this is the point
where everything becomes just a little
bit harder
so in this case let's go to the basics
recently i had a chance to teach pyson
to my girlfriend
and after an hour of me blabbering about
how pyson is great unbelievable and
amazing
we we reached this
this example program
and after we after we wrote it i thought
okay that's the point where
you usually start learning about ifs
loops and all other bells and whistles
but i thought have we really explored
everything uh in this example
and i started trying to
complicate it with all the knowledge we
had at this point
and i ended up with this little program
yep so what's interesting about it
is it's very simple but
when i when i showed it to my friends
who are
not all of them are poison programmers
but
very often they would get confused and
they wouldn't give the right answer
so you can take a second to think about
what this program is going to print
to the screen
nice your second is over
so let's see what's happening
we nest a bunch of things together
we go to the most deeply nested
one and it's just a print function which
isn't doing anything because
it is not being executed it's passed as
an argument to another print function
now what does a print function do with
its argument
it prints it to the screen now we know
how we print text to the screen but how
do we print
a function to the screen well in python
a function is an object and
objects have magic methods
which describe how those objects should
be converted into text representation
so basically this should print whatever
text representation is assigned to the
print object
now after that we print
the result of the previous print
function now what is the result of a
print function
well a print function shouldn't
calculate any
value for it so it is not supposed to
return anything
that's why we're getting none so this
should just print
none and
that's what happens now you may notice
that
for for such a simple problem program
that's
quite a complex explanation
but if you
know how it works most python programs
you read are going to be easy for you
because no matter how clean code is or
how much code there is
if you know that a function
accepts arguments and returns value and
are able to trace where that happens
you'll you won't have any problem
figuring out
a complex code base
but
but still many people get confused with
this program
right so let's take this
example to async io but before we do
let's talk about generators because
generators
are very interesting in the sense that
very few people understand generators
and there's a good reason for it
half of pyson community is devoted to
web development
which is the part i'm mostly
busy doing most of the time and
usually when you go to a python
interview
and a question about generators
arises this is how it goes the
interviewer asks
what are generators and you say
well generators are those functions
where you use yields instead of returns
uh and the interviewer goes okay so so
why would you
need such such a function and you say
um well if we wanted to generate a
sequence of numbers
um we wouldn't have to store all the
numbers
in the list taking up a lot of memory we
could just generate them one at a time
and this way our program would be more
memory efficient at this point
interviewer says okay
great job let's move on to the next
question but the result is
that's a very primitive understanding of
generators
and and there is a point because we
don't
generate uh and there is a point because
we don't generate
uh sequences of numbers in web
development every day
but the problem is if you want to do
sync io
you better understand the generator as
well
so let's let's explore that a little bit
let's say
you have a sequence of numbers to
generate let's say
even numbers
so say you pass two values
which define the bounds of your even
numbers
generated and let's do it without
generators
you create an empty list of numbers
if it's an even number
you append it to the list fair enough
now let's see if our function works
and it does
where the problem is that if you were to
go
a little bit beyond
you would have to wait until the numbers
are printed out
but what if we do it using generators
so first of all we remove this return
statement
we remove this list
and we just add a yield here
right
you may notice that it doesn't work the
way we're used to
have it work so what do we do
when we run this function we get a
generator object
which doesn't do much by itself
similarly
if we uh execute an essence function
like that we're going to get a core
routine which is not going to run
by itself so what do we do
well let's
[Applause]
let's assign this generator to a
variable so what can we do with a
generator
well we can pass it to the next function
and this way we are going to get the
next consecutive
value from this generator
so basically we're moving on to the next
yield using this loop
now you may notice that
if we do this enough times
we are going to get an exception
so why is that well
if there are no more yields left to
yield for a generator it throws a stop
iteration error
but fun thing is if we
loop over a generator
we don't see that exception
[Applause]
and if we do it like this the numbers
are being printed out from the beginning
so why is that well that is because
a for loop handles this exception for
you
but for the sake of it let's rewrite
this program using a while loop
so let's say while true
we are going
to take the next number
and print it
now if we do it like that we'll reach a
stop iteration exception so let's
handle that
[Applause]
and there's a program
[Music]
now what if we wanted to have two of
those
[Applause]
and say we want to generate numbers from
the number 100 to 110.
now one thing we could do is
we could do something like this
so you may notice that
if we do it like this those generators
are being ran
at the same time interesting huh
problem is this program hangs it hangs
because here
i forgot to break the loop
but the problem is if we break the loop
there's this is a little bit dangerous
because if we have more generators
we might break before
all generators complete maybe we'll
break when the first races
um stop iteration
so let's handle that quickly
let's let's wrap it into a function
or let's call it loop we're going to
pass
a bunch of generators in
then here we are going to
iterate over this those generators and
we are going to try
to get the next value
but we would also like to get rid of
those generators
that are completed so we are going to
so we are going to
delete those generators we do not need
um also we have to check
in this while loop if there are any
generators remaining
and if not we're going to end the loop
so let's see how that works
and that works perfectly our program
executes and terminates
and now let's let's review how this
works so we create two generators
because it's important to understand it
because it gets confusing very quickly
so we create two of those generators
those are generator objects which we
pass in a list
we start an infinite loop we check if
this list is not
empty if it's
if it's not empty we go and run this for
loop if it's empty
we exit so if it's not empty
we iterate over those generators so in
this case we go to even numbers
generator
which counts from 0 to 10
we try to get the next value from it if
everything's fine we print it
which you can see here
and then we go to the next generator in
the loop
which is this one which comes from 100
to 110
we print the value and then we go back
to the start of the while loop
we check if there are any generators
left there are
we go to the for loop we repeat this
until the first generator hits stop
iteration error
we delete the generator go to the next
one
print the value delete the generator go
to the start of the while loop
there are no more generators we return
and that's how it works now what
if we try to apply it to the example in
the beginning
so instead of generating even numbers
we're gonna say hello
get rid of the arguments
print hello
import time
sleep for one second
print goodbye
get rid of this
and create two generator objects
remember we have to call those
because if we don't this is just a
function
this is a generator object refer to the
example
with print in the beginning now jokes
aside
let's run it and see how it goes
and we have exactly the same situation
we had in the beginning
[Music]
now this is unexpected oh correct this
is not a generator
so let's put a yield here
and let's get rid of the sprint
statement because our generator doesn't
yield any value
it heals a nun so
you can see that now it starts to happen
at the same time which is interesting
now let's just quickly recap what this
yield is doing here
because this is the point where it might
get just a little bit too confusing
so we go into this loop with
those two generators and what happens
is we start looping
over them we get the first one
we execute next on it so this function
is being executed we print hello
we reach a yield and this is when this
next function
returns so at this point we go to the
next generator which is
this one we print hello
and we yield and the next function
returns
for loop finishes we go back to the
start of the while loop
we start the for loop again and we try
to execute next on this generator
now this yield is finished
so we go to the sleep function
we sleep for two seconds we print
goodbye
and we raise a stop iteration error this
generator is deleted
we go back to the for loop same thing
happens for the second generator
and um we go back to the start of the
while loop no generators are left
we terminate and this is exactly how it
works
but if you look closely you may notice
that those two hellos are printed
instantly
then we sleep for two seconds before
goodbye
and then we sleep again for two seconds
and that's not what we want
because we want to sleep simultaneously
we want those two goodbyes to be printed
at the same time
so how do we do it well you see
this program is synchronous and
it executes sequentially
deterministically so
if we have this time that sleep here
this program has to sleep for two
seconds we can't get around it
so maybe we can implement our fake sleep
what if this loop would get
a lot of yields here which would yield
chaotically for for two seconds
before we can resume again
now that might be a fair solution
let's say um
we have start time here
and then we create a loop
which loops until two seconds pass
so we say if
current time
minus start is less than two seconds
then
we are going to yield
and we may remove this one so let's see
what happens
two hellos are printed the goodbyes are
printed
ladies and gentlemen we just invented
this nko
now let's just uh think about it so we
run the first generator print hello go
here start this loop
we yield so we move on to the next
generator
when the next generator does the same
thing we come back to the first one
we go to the next iteration of the loop
now it happens very quickly
and this is false because two seconds
haven't passed yet
so we yield again and then this happens
until
two seconds pass and first generator
completes
then instantly we go to the next one
now this code can start getting a little
bit messy so let's
make a sleep function for it
we say for how many seconds we want to
sleep
we copy this code here
so what do we do we say sleep
for two seconds we write the yield here
because if we don't this is not going to
be a generator we're going to get an
error here
actually let's do just that we get
an error non-type object is not an
iterator which is quite confusing
but this happens because we pass a
normal function too
next actually no we're not passing the
normal function because here
we execute hello instead of yielding we
return
we return none because that's the
default return in python
so here we are passing to non-values we
try to run next on a non
and we get this beautiful little error
so let's not do that
let's add a yield here and
run the program now it may seem
like the program works but you may
notice we're not sleeping
that's not what we want now that is
happening
because here we create a generator
object and we yield it
so this is completed instantly
basically this function is not fired
now how do we do that because that's a
valid behavior
right so in python there is this yield
from syntax
and basically this means that we want to
run next here and
we want to basically redirect whatever
this function yields
and again our program works
so what we do here is
we invented snko so
let's maybe try it out with a senko
let's say we create a main function
which is a quarantine
and
in this function we
replace our loop with snko gather
and instead of having the stuff in a
list
we're going to do it this way because
that's the way
snko api is designed
[Applause]
we run our main function we get rid of
this loop
and if we run it
it works exactly the same way so
notice that here we are not passing core
routines
um we are passing generators
which uh i don't think this is even
supported by a cincio
api but since there's duck typing
um which means if we can if we can yield
from it
then it's a core thing um it works
now this is all beautiful
right but there's one strange thing
we still have this very weird sleep here
so you may say okay we have a
simple example to demonstrate how snko
works
but what if we want to use some
libraries we love
what if we want to use requests what if
we want to use database clients
are we going to have to write our own
database clients which
specify at which points
we may go ahead and run something else
while we
wait and the answer is yes
and that's a that's a big problem right
if you want to do snko
you have to have libraries that support
us in ko and
explicitly say where we want to
stop doing whatever we're doing and move
on to another thing while we are waiting
for results
so what if we do not want to do that
well there is a way
what if there was absolutely no way to
implement
time implement sleeping in our own way
so we would go here and we would sleep
for two seconds
we would get rid of this
and we would get rid of a sinkhel
we would
make a thread
out of hello
[Applause]
then we would make another thread
then we would start those threads
now you may notice that we get almost
almost the same result um
what's beautiful here is that we don't
have to implement our own sleep function
so what what's all this hype with s and
ko
why can't we just use threads
now the problem with threads
is that threads have no idea
when we actually want to wait for
something so
what might happen
if we have a program that does a bunch
of stuff here before sleep and a bunch
of stuff here
after sleep um we might switch
to the next thread not while we are
sleeping
but while we are doing something else
and
and the problem with threads in python
is that we have something called the
jill which basically says
in python you cannot run multiple
threads
at the same time
um so basically python has a bunch of
those threads
and it switches at regular intervals
between those threads now you may ask
why what's the point of it
if we have 10 threads and we can only
execute one
at a time why bother having 10 threads
why can't we just write an
asynchronous program without threads it
shouldn't be any faster right
well not always because look at this
program
even though only one pro one thread is
executed at a time
basically we switch between those all
the time
but if we switch during the sleep
function
uh basically we we optimize it
right because we may switch between
those two threads during those two
seconds
but because we were switching this sleep
function got started in both threads
at the same time
maybe a better explanation would be a
network request right
if you send five network requests and
wait for a response from each of them
that's long but if you use threads
and you switch between them and you run
one thread at a time
you still are going to fire those five
requests
almost at the same time right they they
would be fired one after another
but you wouldn't wait for a response
before you fire another request
and basically
threads in this example work like
stupid quarantines which don't know what
are
the the best places to switch execution
to another core routine
but they do it at specific intervals
so what should we use should we use
threads should we use a senko
well it depends and to demonstrate it
uh let's switch to some more complicated
examples
so check this out
let's say we want to run
four thousand of those hellos
each one sleeps for three seconds
now here we have an example with snko
what we are doing is we are creating 4
000 core routines
each coordinates just sleeps for three
seconds
and we measure
the time it takes to finish this program
in a quite
naive way but let's see what happens
four thousand core routines
we finish in three seconds
that's impressive
now let's do it using threads very
similar create 4000 threads
start measuring run all those threads
wait for all of those threads to finish
easy peasy
we run the program
takes a bit longer why
well you have to create those threads
and to create threads
you have to copy a little bit of memory
between them
and those switches between threads they
take time
now in this case everything is happening
cooperatively
and it makes sense we bother to write a
whole new sleep function
we would like to have a better
performance
now we also have another way to run a
bunch of things at
the same time and that's another way
is using processes now
there is a big difference between
processing and threads
you can't execute a bunch of threads at
the same time
but you can execute a bunch of processes
at the same time
why is that because in case of processes
we are actually going to run 4
000 pythons at the same time
when we use threads we run one python
interpreter
which has a bunch of threads to deal
with here
we run 4 000 python processors which are
all synchronous but since there's
a bunch of them they're happening
at the same time now let's see how well
this program performs
and you may notice that it doesn't
perform that well
now why is that you may ask
well that's because we are running 4 000
pythons on one system
it's heavy for this little pc
so this looks like a disaster right
let's terminate it
question is what's the point of having
processes if if they are so
so heavy and so slow well
let's look at a bunch of other examples
so instead of sleeping
we are going to send network requests
so let's go to scale here's what we are
going to do
we are going to send 200 requests
to google sorry google for doing this
um in this example i wanted to spin up
my own server
and do it on my own server the problem
with that
is my server wouldn't handle
200 requests happening almost at the
same time
so our measurements wouldn't be accurate
so basically we are ddosing google
but google is smart google is going to
notice we're doing that
and google is going to just reject those
requests quickly
but the speed of
one such rejection is still
an http response
so it's it's still fine to test it
to test this program with such a network
request
so let's see what happens we create 200
core routines
uh each quarantine creates a session and
sends a get request to google
easy peasy let's see how it runs
beautiful we just sent 200 network
requests
in one second let's do it using threads
again same thing 200 threads
200 requests to google and you may
notice that in case of snko we're using
as a different library which
supports snkio
running the example with threads
takes five seconds still a good result
now let's run 200 processes
and we're starting to get disappointed
because it's
the results are very similar to
actually we perform a bit better here
but notice that
here i've been measuring
uh this time when we already created 200
processes
so you may see that this process of
creating processes
is very time consuming and their
execution is fairly quick
but still it performed the worst of all
and snko was a clear winner here
but let's switch our examples
up a little bit so we are going to go
and run another example
up
okay so what we are doing here
is
we are going to have a quarantine which
sleeps for one second
and then decides to check if this number
is prime
now this number is not prime that's why
this
silly algorithm is going to take a long
time to figure that out
roughly one second um
and we run five of those core routines
let's see how it performs
and it takes seven seconds
so why is that
well what happens is those sleeps are
happening simultaneously
but then we have a task
sorry not a task we have a function we
have a function
which is blocking we
are running some numbers through it
and on our computer uh
our cpu does that
so since only one thread is being
executed
it happens sequentially we can't we can
just tell our cpu to
somehow clone itself and
and count those prime numbers at the
same time
so that's why um
snko has no possible way
of optimizing this function
now let's run it using threads
and you may notice that we have similar
results
in fact almost identical
so in this case
threads perform just as well as snko now
if we have a bunch of threads why
doesn't this happen quicker
well same thing here you can notice um
how this how does jill
actually works because if we could
execute those threads at the same time
then we could run those calculations
in parallel right but we can't
because only one thread is happening at
the same time so
um actually here we are switching
between different threads as they're
doing this calculation and that's just
slowing us down
there's no point in that
so that's why we get a similar result
but
let's do it with multi-processing and
run
five processes
now that happened in three seconds and
here
we actually measured um everything
from from creating
those processes to
to to executing them so it happened
much faster it happened two times faster
than everything else
and why is that well here we have the
sleep
which async io and threads uh deal with
really nicely multiprocessing deals with
it
uh just as well because even though
we have five threads which all run this
function
all of those five threads hit this sleep
and those
sorry five processors hit the slip
and they wait together at the same time
and then they execute this function
each process executes its own version of
this function at the same time
so that's why we're getting such
enormous speeds here
so what's better threads multiprocessing
or
snko i guess by this point
you you know that
it depends right but let me show you one
more example
so what we would like to do in this case
let's go to snko
we are going to send 10 requests to
google
but before we do that we
run the prime number function we send
those 10 requests we run this prime
function again
and we use snko for that
now here's what's happening we run those
functions sequentially
to check if this number is prime
we run those requests almost at the same
time
and then we run this function again
sequentially
and it takes us 13 seconds
let's do the same thing with threads now
at this point
you may predict what the result is going
to be
right
and results are roughly the same
as they are forcing ko
a little bit longer than 13 seconds
which is expected
right um
now let's do it with processes
now we may expect that processes are
going to make
this faster
right we finish in five seconds
um but here's the thing
what if we have to do it 500 times
right we know our machine is not going
to
to cope with that as well and here
but let's think let's think of it right
uh what are the strengths of snk
snko is really great if you have to wait
for an input output operation now
when is snko not that great one you have
to execute a cpu bound task
but that's something multiprocessing is
really good at
so here's one thing we could
do
why don't we just combine both of them
so here what we are going to do is
we are going to execute five processes
but
each process is going to have its own
event loop
and each process
is going to run the score routine
where it looks for a prime number
sends 10 requests
and then looks for a prime number again
now you may notice that in
case of uh the multi-processing example
before
what we did was we would run five
processes here but each process would
have to send 10 requests sequentially
but what if each process had its own
async io
and could send those 10 requests at the
same time and then wait for results
well that's what we did here
and it gave us the best speed of
all now to be honest this is not my idea
this idea is from talk by
john reeves on snko and multiprocessing
and he combines this stuff into
um i believe aio multi-processing
library
i tried to use that library for this
example but
somehow i didn't manage to get the
speeds i got by just
doing this manually without library i'm
not sure if i wasn't doing something
correct
um but but that's the thing here
i will show you one more example
let's say we have a cat
cats are great right so why don't we
have one
now this cat can do
a whole bunch of things it can eat
it can have free time and by free time i
mean sleep
why do we have this function in the
middle here why can't we just
sleep if that's the only thing he does
well you will notice in a minute
so we have five synchronous cats and
we'll let each cat
exist for a little bit
so what happens is one cat starts eating
gets some free time sleeps
wakes up eats
so it's slow basically those cats take
turns existing
not nice right so let's say we wanted to
optimize it
well we may create an
sync get right we could say okay import
import snko
and
please
create those cats and
cat exists
for cat and cats
unpack this and there we go right
we could make this according
and now we have everything
oh right
[Applause]
we have to use gather for it
okay and we run it
it's still synchronous but let's say
that this sync cat comes from a library
which we can't edit so
our solution would be either to copy the
library
make this stuff as ink
right or
we could
just create an async cat which inherits
the synchronous cat
and switches things up a bit
but let's say that this have free time
um okay
switches things up a bit right
so here we would await have some free
time
and have some free time we would await
sleep
we would make the supporting we would
copy the sleep function
and then we would await snk or sleep
and then use this async cat instead of
the sink cat
and we wouldn't touch the eat method
because there's no way we could
optimize it right so let's run it
and you may see that it's quite fast all
the cats
go to sleep at the same time all the
cats wake up at the same time
but what if this have some free time
function
has a lot more code right
and what if for some reason we can't
modify it for example
maybe this function uses some stuff from
c
and the library is being compiled to c
so when you import it into python you
don't have access to the source code of
this function you just
know that it calls sleep
so can you make
um can you make it call sleep but
for sleep to somehow underneath switch
itself to a quara tin
that's the first idea i got because
i like to do weird stuff but as much as
i tried
i couldn't succeed at it
so what you could do is you would have
to turn to our dear friends threads
which weren't performing the best but
remember
those had an advantage
because you didn't have to rewrite
everything to snko
to use the
to use the benefits of threads when it
comes to
io bound tasks
so let's see how it plays out
in the exist method
we get the event loop and we
use something called run in executor and
we pass
the synchronous function to this
executor
this non means that we are going to use
the default executor
which is threadpool executor in essence
you have you also have the
multi-process executor but in this case
we want to optimize something that is
not cpu bound
so thread executor would be a better
option for us right
and basically that's what we do we do
not touch any of those functions
we make this into a core routine
and actually this is unnecessary
we make this into a core routine let's
say we inherit here
right
and let's see how it performs
it performs very similarly to the first
snko example
so we basically managed to get around
this problem
without having to rewrite everything to
a syncio
using threads in the spot where we can't
use
snko and use an snko for the rest
and that's pretty cool and what's cool
about it
is that we can take advantage of both
snko threading and multiprocessors
to solve different kinds of problems and
we don't have to
to use something exclusively and
we don't have to fight over what's
better because everything is better
for different kinds of problems
now question is where can you go from
here
first of all
check out john reza's talks
on snko those are phenomenal this is the
sinking outside
jill talk where he discusses how we
could take advantage of
snko and
multiprocessing also from genres we have
a talk
which is called what is a quarantine
anyway
and in the stock he explores how
how core routines work underneath in
depth
and it's also very very very informative
and next thing is
check out
thinking about concurrency
and this is a talk by raymond hettinger
there are two versions of it both are
amazing
basically he explains the idea i
explained
or better say i just explained what he
explained
now one other thing with snko
is its api is changing rapidly
so watching talks made by core
developers of
snko where they discuss changes to the
api
and what they plan to change or what
they think is
was a bad design in the past that may be
a better design in the future
is also very very helpful
i can also recommend this talk by andrew
svetlov he's
also a core developer and he explores
some of the things you shouldn't do in
snko
and this information is also
a gold mine because some of the points
he makes i couldn't find anywhere else
and one another talk recommend with all
of my heart
is wukashlanga's senko and music which
he did on the previous code dive and
that talk is phenomenal
because he shows you a completely
different take on snko and shows you
what you can do with snko
apart from sending network requests at
the same time
so he just controls midi synthesizers
from his code
uh simultaneously using snko so that's
amazing
now thanks a lot for sticking with me um
for this talk
let me know what you liked what you
didn't like and what i could do better
um definitely if you're interested in
the topic check out the talks i
uh i showed in the end and
have fun at codedive see you
very soon probably in a year
not sure about that but you can still
find me by the links in the description
chat and
see you soon thanks for your attention
and thanks for sticking around
alexi thank you very much great
presentation
this is code dive don't go away we're
going to take a short break
but stay tuned for more